Big B wolf is so [ __ ] cool the wolf
among us episode 1 faith the wolf among
us is a new series by Telltale Games you
know the guys who gave us that kick-ass
Walking Dead game that point and click
game that was so cool and so good at one
game of the air now they have a new
series out it's gonna be five episodes
long just like The Walking Dead was and
it is the wolf among us it's pretty much
fairy tale characters living in modern
times I'll incognito you know people
don't know that these people are fables
they're they call them fables so you
have the Huntsman you have Beauty and
the Beast I'll having marriage problems
and [ __ ]
I love seeing fairy tale creatures
brought down on such a reality and if
you look at fairy tales the [ __ ] and
a lot of fairy tales was the big bad
wolf and you play as him he's a normal
looking dude he's big be wolf
like I said he's awesome cuz he's really
damaged and you can tell he was really
bad back in the day he's a werewolf so
he can wolf out and really rip into [ __ ]
he doesn't want to be an [ __ ] anymore
but he's still just he's kind of a dark
and damaged guy he is an [ __ ] he's
just he won't eat you he'll just be like
whatever he wants a perspective big me
wolf reminded me of John Constantine
like straight up you can tell he's
damaged he's seen so much [ __ ] it has
worn him down to the bone he just wants
to smoke his cigarettes and not deal
with all this [ __ ] that he clearly
has to deal with so ultimately you're
the big bad wolf who's investigating a
murder that happened to someone in Fable
town and now you go question a bunch of
these fable people and then the plot
thickens you see more characters you
recognize from fairy tales and it just
gets bigger and bigger and cooler and
cooler seriously this game is awesome
it's completely kick-ass I was looking
forward to it so much I played the demo
at PAX I love it now he played the
entirety of episode 1 and I loved it
because like The Walking Dead you do
pick your dialogue I always love it when
games give you your own flavor to
situational circumstance but the
characters are still the characters you
know so I mean Big B's not gonna be like
oh it's ok citizen is a hey old lady let
me help you across the street she's
still usually kind of a prick in
everything example I was fighting this
dude it gave me the option to rip his
arm off or not
so granted I did throw the first punch
the dude was being a douche that was my
decision
but the game gave me the option do you
want to rip his arm off and I was like
you know what no he's suffered enough
not a complete dude I'm gonna fights
happening you know you push left or
or whatever the screen tells you to do
and you can see objects around you you
can click your cursor on them you'll
take the guy and smash them into him
then you gotta line the cursor up to a
partner's body push through for me it's
our two because its ps3 then you hit his
shoulder poke at is I do whatever the
game is telling you to do because if you
mess it up the dudes gonna kick your ass
yeah that's a bit of intensity to it
reminded me of Mass Effect 2 when they
added the action triggers and you're
like oh okay so it's not just talking
now I get to do [ __ ] and beat people up
and I love the fact that you're
investigating murders because you go
question people and you can catch them
in their lives like wait a minute you
said that so how is this that if what
you said is true you're lying to me toad
don't lie to me tell me the truth you
really feel like you personally as the
gamer are making progress in this game
and in this investigation and yet that's
right the decisions are back you know
those game-changing decisions that you
make you make a judgment call you're
like that was the wrong call now shit's
different example there was this one
scenario where it's like all right where
do you want to go first here or here I
made my choice and someone died because
of it now I can tell you who no spoilers
in this all I'm saying is I googled it
afterwards and afterwards I was like oh
yeah if you chose the other one people
would have live and now people are dead
I'm like you know what I'm gonna let
that ride because that is the game not
sure how that will affect chapter 2 I'm
just saying it's a thing and I like that
thing it's cool going through this game
and you see new characters you're like I
know that character is from that fairy
tale oh that's from that fairy tale it
appeals to the kid in you and the adult
in you and it's just a really cool
hybrid mix of those two worlds so the
wolf among us episode 1 is a really
great and promising start to another
great series from Telltale Games it's
chapter 1 of 5 of an entire game so I'm
not gonna write chapter 1 up because
it's 1/5 of a game it's like me picking
up the last of us 1/5 of the way through
turning it off me like this is what I
rate it now you gotta play til the end
so I'm gonna rate up the wolf among us
after I play all the chapters they're
sequentially being released like The
Walking Dead was I got the season passed
because Who am I kidding I'm gonna get
all of it's not like I'm gonna finish
chapter 1 that leaves off on an awesome
cliffhanger and be like no you know what
done but the wolf among us was great it
had good dialogue great humor in it also
it's kind of dark humor because Bigby
wolf is kind of a dark person I loved
all the other characters too you team up
with Snow White and you investigate this
these crimes going on
I like toad I liked the Huntsman I liked
all of it I'll say this chapter 1 is
definitely worth downloading for the $5
it cause if it doesn't hook
don't like it cool you don't have to
keep playing but if it does hook you you
will have no problem dropping 20 bucks
on the entire game but this is a great
start I'm glad telltale games still have
it you would think maybe they struck
gold once with The Walking Dead and
that's that now awful Margaret is pretty
awesome myself fairy tale characters
what's your favorite fairy tale
character that you'd like to see in
modern time because it would be awesome
whoever it is comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more